we have it in your stomach ha ha it's
like turkey loved' juice ah ok
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom I'm drinking some really really
sour solve Blanc tonight it's just like
the fridge leftovers you know when you
have the wine that's been in your fridge
for a while that someone brought to your
house and you're like I don't really
like this kind but like I'm not gonna
waste it's my phone is shattered to
oblivion and every time that I text
somebody I get charged of glass in my
fingers right now so tonight we're going
to talk about the worst things about
texting so first when I text someone and
then I see the little bubble appear in
the text and then it disappears it's
like emotional torture because I'm
sitting here like oh why would you do
that to me because it's always in
response to a text that's either
emotional or time-sensitive I've tried
to comprehend what kind of situation
could occur where you start typing a
text and then you stop and the only
explanation I can think of is you were
standing atop a volcano and you're
trying to take a really great picture of
the center of the volcano when then you
drop your phone whatever I text my
husband something very very important
like do you want pizza for dinner
tonight and he types something and then
I never get it oh you didn't text me
back guess what we're having tuna noodle
casserole for dinner tonight
I suck at making tuna noodle casserole
you could have been having delicious
cheesy Greece bread with me but you can
text me back next the entire etiquette
of dating and texting no I haven't dated
in a very long time but when I did date
there was this weird time period that
you're supposed to wait before you text
somebody back it's like two hours is
acceptable because then you seem busy
and unavailable I don't want someone
who's too busy for me I want someone
who's interested in me so if I'm free I
will text you back if I'm interested in
you I will text you back if I'm busy I
will text you back when I'm free and
it's not this oh I better seem busy
because then he'll like me more well I'd
be dating a guy and text him and he
wouldn't answer for a couple hours I'd
be like I know the
sitting on a bed with no pants eating a
cheeseburger you are not too busy to
text me back this too busy to text
persona is not attractive and that's why
I married a phone call kind of guy my
husband likes to call people and that's
why I love him so Cheers
next when someone sends me a text and
then immediately calls me to ask if I
got their cat first you didn't even give
me a chance to open your text second if
what you had to say was all wrapped up
in a text why are you calling me to tell
me the same exact thing and my mom is
one of the worst offenders at this
because she will send me a text it's
like a picture of a dress being like do
you like this dress and then she'll call
me literally two seconds later being
like did you get my text and sometimes
the text has not even gone through so
then I have to be on the phone like okay
let me put you on speaker let me check
my text no it still isn't okay no it's
going through now look at the picture
yeah I like the dress
next when I get a text that says can we
talk later it makes me so nervous cuz
I'm like what is it you not want to be
my friend did I do something wrong
what'd I do I retraced my cell for the
last four months what did I do in the
last four months can I pissed you off
somehow what is happening so you're
basically sending me a text saying hey I
want you to worry until the time that we
can actually talk if you send something
back saying what they're like oh no
we'll talk about it later in the time
between when you send me that text and
we actually talk I formulated 80,000
different things that lead to the world
ending and then when it gets in the time
that we actually talk it's always
something like hey do you like my new
haircut next when I get a text and I
read it and I was in the middle of
something else and then I forget to
answer it for like two weeks this
happens to me all the time when I'm at
work I'll be in the middle of a shoot or
I'll be in the middle conference call
and someone will text me saying hey do
you think I should wear this shirt or
this shirt to my date tonight and I read
it and I'm like oh yeah I like that
shirt and set it down and I forget for
like two weeks I'm a mother of two I
have a husband who's very needy I work
full-time I have a million
responsibilities it's really hard for me
to remember to reply to a text when I
read it and already like closed it out
and put my phone down then it's kind of
just like out of sight out of mind
then I'm the jerk who two weeks later is
like I like the red top I will take full
responsibility I'm so sorry I am a
contributor to one of the worst things
about texting and last group text I have
gotten group text to me and ten other
people at a time and it'll be like hey
just want you to know my birthday
parties this Saturday something you
could easily text all ten of us
individually but no you had to do it as
a group text so then all ten of those
people have to be like oh my gosh how's
your boyfriend how's your life how's
your job what's going on all these
individual conversations appear within
the group text and so I go to my phone
and I have like 87 notifications of text
messages none of which are for me is
when I delete the message conversation I
still get notified the next time someone
sends a message it doesn't take me out
of the conversation and it's so
frustrating so the only way to get out
of it is to be that jerk who's like hey
guys can you take this to your own
private text conversation because this
has nothing to do with me and so listen
that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if you have any problems with texting
that you want to talk about or a topic
you want me to talk about in a future
episode leave it in the comments or text
me and this is a real phone number and
if you're very lucky I might text you
back till next time oh my god get me off
this group text don't
you